first place for the far-left and a
personal triumph for this man bordel
hammer law has governed this state for
the past five years now he thinks he's
won another five investiga attack for
chewing mangos attack for chewing an
important day for throwing gear a great
day for Thuringia in the 30th
anniversary of the border opening such
an intense elections and an option on
which the people of the country decide
for themselves how the future of the
country will be shaped his main
challengers have been from the far right
AFD whose leader here is Bjorn Hurka a
man who believes the National Holocaust
Memorial shames his country and who
strongly opposed to immigration and
multiculturalism those messages helped
him more than double his party's vote
share the Sun is rising above the east
and soon we will let the Sun Shine above
all of Germany we have made the east
blue and in just a few years we will be
a People's Party for the whole of
Germany collectively the vote for the
two political extremes is more than 50%
at a time when many in the old communist
East Germany feel disillusioned with
what 30 years in reunited Germany has
brought them for the Christian Democrats
this is a blow whose effect was clearly
acknowledged by its lead candidate here
for Thuringia in their Democratic Center
this is a bitter result we fought for
this Democratic Center and this
Democratic Center did not get a majority
all of which means finding a stable
majority to govern this state for the
next five years could be difficult one
analyst believes the far left may try to
govern alone maybe the solution should
be a minority government and then more
minority governments could follow as an
exit from this impasse created by the
all against the AFD split in Germany but
so far at least all of the other parties
maintained they are against the AFT
although Sunday's vote was for this
state parliament its message will
resonate at the national level many East
Germans are unhappy with the political
process and they're turning to the
parties of the extremes to show it
Dominic Kane al Jazeera at the
Thuringian Parliament